- [Radio] I don't believe you.
There is no like war between
ISIS and American soldiers.
- Hello.
- (Driver) Hi.
- (Claudia and Amber) Hi.
- Do you have a phone charger?
- (Driver) Yeah.
- Thank you, appreciate it.
- [Radio] Educate me.
- (Claudia) Buckle up.
(radio)
- You guys like riddles?
- Mm, I guess?
- Sure.
- If you get it right
before we get to your place,
ride's on me.
- I mean, sure, why not?
- Yeah, okay.
- You can always find me in the past,
I can be created in the present,
but the future will never taint me.
What am I?
- Can I phone a friend?
(chuckles)
- That would be cheating.
- This is like that cab show.
- Yup, yeah it is.
- Memories?
- (Driver) Nope, no, sorry.
- [GPS] You have arrived
at your destination.
- Well I tried.
- (Driver) Ohp, let me get that for you.
- (Claudia) I thought that was
a pretty good guess, memories.
- (Amber) Thanks.
- (Claudia) Better than
anything this guy's got.
- You don't know that.
- I got a few guesses.
- We could still get a free ride.
(screams)
- Oh my god, what's going on?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
- No cheating. Back in your seat.
- Alright, alright.
(dramatic music)
- You can always find me in the past.
I can be created in the present.
But the future will never taint me.
What am I?
(dramatic music)
- A dream, the answer's a dream.
- Help! Help! We're trapped in the car!
- Fuck, ah!
(screaming)
- No, no, please don't, please don't,
please don't, please don't.
- Wrong answer.
- (Claudia) No!
No please!
(crying)
(breathing loudly)
- Why are you doing this?
- (Driver) You can always
find me in the past.
I can be created in the present.
But the future will never taint me.
What am I?
- Are you serious?
- You can always find me in the past.
- Fuck you! I don't ...
I don't know!
- [GPS] You have arrived
at your destination.
(dramatic music)
- Yesterday, it's yesterday.
It's in the past, and
it's not in the future,
but you can make it in the present.
It's yesterday, it's yesterday.
It's yesterday!
- Have a nice night.
(door unlocks)
(breathing heavily)
(car vrooms)
(screams)
(engine rumbles)